Speaker 1: For the second day in a row.
I have a really good example for you of when
an interviewer realizes their guest isn't
answering the question and keeps asking the
same question and it makes the guest look
really dumb when they don't answer the question.
In this case, we're talking about Jared Kushner.
Jared Kushner is Donald Trump's son in law.
And Jared Kushner was asked here by a cable
from Sky News, why did Donald Trump have those
documents at his house?
Why did Donald Trump have those documents
at his house?
Why did Trump have the documents at his house?
And much like yesterday's example, where former
Democratic Senator Al Franken kept asking
Alice Stewart, a Republican strategist, when
was a Supreme Court nomination just not even
acted on?
Because it was the last year before an election?
When when, when, when, when Jared Kushner
doesn't answer the question.
So we're going to take a look at this.
And, of course, Jared Kushner just wants to
talk about his book.
And in doing so, he says a lot of things that
don't make any sense as is very common with
these folks.
Let's take a listen to this piece.
Speaker 3: Shattered their very tranquil pace
for the family page shattered by an FBI raid.
Why did the president take home toxic top
secret document?
Speaker 4: You have to ask him that question.
But what I will say is if you look at my book,
you'll see that he was under constant attack.
Speaker 3: He took top secret documents home,
potentially risking the security of the United
States.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I think that it's something
that, again, this seems like it's an issue
of paperwork that should be.
Speaker 1: By the way, that's a new talking
point that they've settled on.
First it was the documents were planted, then
it was declassified, then it was I gave them
back when they asked me, but I didn't.
And there were empty folders.
And now it's listen, whatever it is that took
place with the documents, it's a paperwork
issue.
And this is a way to not have to account for
by I mean they already told the lie.
So it's a little late.
But the idea of it's a paperwork issue understand
the motivations of that.
It's basically saying no matter what documents
there were, no matter where they were, no
matter who moved them, no matter what their
classification status was, it's a minor issue.
That's what it means to say it's a paperwork
issue.
And Kay Burley doesn't let Kushner get away
with it.
Speaker 4: It'll be worked out between DOJ
and him.
I don't know what he took or what he didn't
take, but I think right now we're relying
on leaks to the media, which is the same things.
Speaker 3: That we search for, haven't we,
where it says top secret.
Speaker 1: Yeah, but that could have been
fake.
Two guys that could have been staged.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Like I said, I've seen a lot of allegations
made by the media over my four years that
turned out not to be true.
So I think that this whole thing is actually
elevated.
Speaker 3: So the fact that we see photographs
that say top secret document, we should wait
and see whether or not they were, even though
we're being told by the FBI that they were.
Speaker 1: Isn't the look on Kushner's face
right now basically says it all.
So the pictures released by the FBI.
Of top secret documents with the FBI confirming
that their top secret documents.
We need.
What exactly?
Who's going to tell us?
Right.
If they are not the authority on what the
search warrant turned up?
Who's going to tell us?
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Like I said, I go into my book the accusations
that were made of Trump.
Speaker 3: I just.
If you could answer that question.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
I mean, first of all, he was the United States.
He had the highest clearance in the world.
Say, I don't know if like this maybe a paperwork
issue.
This maybe.
I don't know.
Like I said, I haven't been involved in the
details of it.
Speaker 1: He just has no idea.
At the end of the day, he has no clue.
And again, he floats paperwork issue.
And again, understand that every every single
one of these lines could really be analyzed
and looked at at a deeper level.
Kushner there, when he mentioned it's like
they can't go three words without some kind
of lie or distortion.
When Kushner says he was the president, he
had the highest level of clearance in the
world.
That's not relevant to the legality of taking
boxes of documents to his house.
And as we already know, because it's been
explored in detail, the classification status
of the documents was also not the issue when
it comes to many of the criminal statutes
which Donald Trump may have violated.
So every little detail here, every detail
is a distortion or a misunderstanding or a
lie.
And what I like about this strategy, Al Franken
did it yesterday.
Give me an example of when this was done to
another Supreme Court justice.
Well, listen, I mean, it's just it's precedent.
But if it's precedent, tell me, when was it
done and Alice Stewart couldn't do it?
If you don't know the clip I'm referring to.
It's on the YouTube channel.
You can find it from yesterday.
Same thing here.
Why did he have the documents?
Why did he have the.
Are you saying they weren't actually what
the picture shows they were.
And they crumble.
They crumble because they don't have a defense.
Now, is it believable that Kushner simply
hasn't talked to Trump about this, despite
the fact that we know he's hung out with Trump
a bunch of times since the search warrant
was executed?
It's really not believable.
But he would have been better off focusing
on that from a PR perspective if I were advising
him instead of saying, Well, he has whatever
access he wants because he was the president,
or it's a paperwork issue which minimizes
the fact that we're talking about possible
crimes.
I would have just stuck to I really can't
speak to this.
I just it's it's not about me.
I can't speak to this.
I don't know anything about.
I would have just stuck with that in
that alone.